you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast multiplex fluorescence
immunohistochemistry using the Ulta view
in pseudo plex platform on the like of
biosystem bond rx presented by Tracy de
Geer global product and innovation
manager bond rx like Biosystems and Alex
Clemens principal scientist Boehringer
Ingelheim pharmaceuticals I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by Leica
Biosystems for more information on our
sponsor please visit leica Biosystems
comm now let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenters
Traci de Geer and Alex Clements for
complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Traci you may now begin your
presentation in case they might Alexis
and I wanted to start by just
apologizing I have a cold so you may
hear my cough drop in my mouth as I
speak but I'm if an innovation manager
for the research platform here at lichen
and one of the things that I do in my
position
is bring companies like all of you to
like a in order to form partnerships so
that we can bring innovation to the
researchers
we work with and part of the way that we
do that is through the bond direct
system which is our research platform so
my presentation today is going to walk
you through a little bit about the bond
our platform and how that works with
open innovation to allow researchers
like Alex to bring things on to their
system better brand new so let's get
started and I'll show you a little bit
about the system and how it works with
our is an innovation partners like also
view
so one of the principal things about the
platform that we bring to our customers
is it gets them the opportunity to
explore new ideas and accelerate test
programs and then if you're talking to
people like Ulta view or some of our
other open innovation partners they look
at it as a way to commercialize
discoveries and that's something that
the essence software that we're going to
talk about in just a little bit allows
them to do with the system
now let's start with explore your ideas
and when you're talking about a piece of
automation what do you mean when you say
for your ideas well one of the things
that you can do is if you talk about a
system that you can bring your third
party a fate on to and if you think
about it you see lots of little things
in the check boxes you see
immunofluorescence you see circulating
tumor cells you see TSA which is to
remind we're going to talk about that in
a little bit you see tunnels
you see multiplexing all of those
different things all of those things can
be done on the same platform but you see
that unique little box that's in the
corner this is your test here well when
we go to talk to an open innovation
partner this is somebody that's got
something new and novel that not many
labs are running right now in the
research world we go and actively look
for those people and what we want them
to do is to push the instrument to their
limits and try to get their appe
actually automated on the system and
their FA becomes the next door to here
so in this case it happened to be
ultimate that has the your chest here
button and that's what we've actually
done with them and you're going to see
some other partners that we've done that
through the years with and there's a
whole pipeline of those partners that
actually play on the system so things
that we put on ourselves or things like
the Nova caste or antibodies they put
crea tech probes on there and we have
our own detection chemistry's that we
run on the system that are the exact
same between the clinical instrument and
the research instrument and what we're
trying to do is find new ways to bring
things on to the clinical system through
you exercising what we can do on the
research platform
and there's a long history of doing
things like that so if you look back to
when the very first launder ex was
released in 2011 over the last seven
years or so we formed a whole bunch of
partnership and we've also actually gone
through a whole bunch of innovations of
software each time making the system a
little bit more flexible
and that opens all kinds of
possibilities if you happen to be a
researcher it allows you to do things
went break apart phrase it allows you to
do all kinds of fluorescent multiplexing
it allows you to do IH see the people
tried all kinds of things on the system
you get an endless amount of options
that you can play with that's one of the
things that make make my job easy is I
can walk into a laboratory and talk to a
pharmaceutical company or a biotech
company that's got this great idea and I
can ask them well have you thought about
automating it and then we can kind of
play around to see if there's some way
that we can make that happen
you can do all sorts of freestanding
customization you can play with heat you
can play with do paralyzation
and all of those are things that uLTA
Beauty look at as they were putting
together their new assay
now each company goes through things a
little differently and each one actually
works to get a protocol that they can
put on the system and make work and some
of them start with with assay Center
manual some of them start from the
ground up and build an assay
sometimes its antigen retrieval that
makes all the difference
sometimes with being able to change
incubation times and temperatures
sometimes it's the way that you wash
your slide and each one of those things
contributes to how well an assay will
work on an instrument
sometimes it's bringing able to put a
third party marker onto the system or
sometimes it's not being able to run a
detection chemistry that you want to run
that makes it different now one of the
things that we lean on a lot with our
open innovation partners is they don't
start out running a detection kit that
we create so if you look at someone like
all of you what they do is they take
open containers and they actually pour
their reagents in it and they put them
on the system things don't come in a
container that we make that's what each
of our is an innovation partners does so
as a researcher alex has the same
ability to do something that one of our
open innovation partners so if he
decided he wanted to run a detection
color tomorrow that we as a company
don't make he could go anywhere and buy
that detection color and he could give
that a whirl if he wanted to
that's openness in a system that
researchers like to play with and I come
out of a research lab and being a
researcher I like to tinker so the
ability to tinker on the system is
something that makes most researchers
pretty happy you want to be able to put
what you want on the system when you
want to put on it and a lot of times
it's about being able to do that more
than a lot of things to get your assay
to work
and being able to customize things now
there were a lot of things that when we
started working with all of you had to
be customized some of the reagents
didn't like water so you have to
customize to that and one of the things
at the very end of their procedure was
that it could sit in water so there's
customization that went into their
procedure and that's what happens with
our is an innovation partners and so
they actually helped us create our new
software that came out and that's one of
the things that's so wonderful about
working with researchers is they come
through and they help us become better
now they accelerate your testing program
is something that we value a lot when it
comes to our our customers and our
researchers and our partners
because a lot of times speed is not
something this is important in research
as it is in the clinic but it does help
us get better a lot of times with the
antibodies in the clinical laboratory
you can get those done in about two and
a half hours but one of the things that
the instrument does really well is each
as a drawer run independently
so if we're running something like Ulta
view we can actually run that on one
tray and run something completely
different on another tray and that lets
the instrument function in some ways
like like two separate instruments or
three separate instruments
it also makes things very efficient now
the new instrument that just came out
actually has a way of relieving some of
the strain on the laboratory by adding
some visual management which is
something we didn't have on this
predecessor it actually has bolt bottles
that flash and they flash colors so if
you have an instrument that has a boat
fluid that's low first it will actually
change colors and white and then if it
really gets irritated at you it will
actually turn the bottle red and then it
really expects to get some attention
from that red bottle and the instruments
fairly small now there is a bench top
version of it with the top-of-the-line
instrument actually is a four model but
given the size of some of the other
instruments on the market it tends to be
a little bit smaller so the footprint is
not extremely huge
one of the newest things that came on
the instrument was actually a change in
the software GUI now I get a GUI which
is actually a front screen that you look
at and it was actually redone to give a
little bit more visual management so you
can see you're both bottles on the front
screen you can actually see all the
reagents that you have loaded over on
the right hand side and you can see each
individual drawer and what you have on
it and that just helps you keep track of
things on the instrument a little bit
better you also get that our auditing
controls which is really nice and it
makes it easier to set your runs up
so these were the bought models that we
were talking about so this is the visual
management so if you've actually got a
bottle that is decommissioned it looks
great if you've got one that's in a
natural safe it actually looks just a
little bit back with if you've got one
that needs attention it'll have a white
light behind it and if you have one
that's really in trouble and it gets
very aggravated with you it turns red
the bottles can be at have fluid added
to them on the fly so you don't have to
stop your instruments to do anything to
the vault models you can just remove
them and add fluid to them or unscrew
the lid and just add the fluid to them
and that can help keep the instrument
running without you actually having to
stop and adjust anything
now one of the hallmarks of the
instruments and one of the things that
has worked so well for the researchers
over the years and one of the things
that are as an innovation partners have
found to be one of the keys to success a
lot of times has been the cover tiles
and that lets us do some really unique
things one of the partners I work with
actually works with circulating tumor
cells and the thing that they have found
that helps them the most is the way the
cover tiles actually work because it
actually preserves those very rare cells
in place on the slide so you get
excellent retention of the cells it
actually holds everything in place and
it keeps things from moving around it
also provides a place for the antibodies
to incubate it keeps ourselves from
drying out so it's kind of a hallmark of
the technology but they actually went
back and redid the way that part of
their cells spreader works to suit the
cover tile that was on the instrument
rather than asking us to make a change
to the instrumentation so it's a really
interesting way that these things
sometimes work together
so one of the things that's interesting
about the instrument is the way it
functions in a way that we've been able
to form partnerships based off of the
technology that we bring to the table so
that we can go out and seek other
companies that have really good
technology to bring the researchers and
all of you is the one that we're talking
about today because they have such
wonderful technology but we have a
history of actually forming partnerships
with great companies
so one of the companies that we have a
partnership is PerkinElmer PerkinElmer
does multiplexing
and we have a partnership with a little
company called rear sight where sind is
actually a circulating tumor cell
company and they are fully automated on
the system as well
and the company that were also very
excited about today is all of you and
also do has their ultimate reagents and
they can do their five flex on the
system as well in the fully automated
fashion and this is one that we were
very excited to actually be able to
bring to our researchers and they've
been a wonderful company to work with as
well
we also have a partnership with a little
company called ClearBridge diagnostic
and Claire bridge is actually a company
from Singapore and they are also a
circulating tumor cell company
and probably our longest lives of our
partnerships is with advanced cell
Diagnostics out of California and this
was our first company that went all the
way through our open innovation program
and they started out on the bond our
attic just like all of the other
companies that you just saw and now they
have partnerships goes on the research
side and on the clinical side with us so
they're on more than one instrument
platform with us
so that's how these companies actually
go from the open innovation of the
research and the openness of the system
all the way through to the ability to
commercialize on the clinical side so
it's a wonderful path for companies and
a great collaboration for us as a
company which is why we're so excited to
have Ulta view as part of that family as
companies
and it's a wonderful way for us to be
able to take the freedom and flexibility
that the Bond Direct offers and the
consistent results that we're able to
offer to our partners in conjunction
with their wonderful reagents to be able
to doing something very special to the
researchers today
and it creates a unique pathway a
pathway for an open innovation being
able to offer something unique to the
researchers and hopefully a path forward
to bring something very special to the
clinic at some point in time
and that lets us actually provide a
commercial path for some of our
wonderful partners and hopefully provide
something unique to our customers and
our researchers and hopefully to their
clinical patients in the future
now alex i'm going to hand it over to
you and let you tell them a little bit
more about our special partner all of
you
Tracy give my slides up here
so let me first just speak to my
disclaimers like a bias incidents did
not sponsor the studies that I'm going
to talk to you about and the opinions
expressed in these presentations are my
opinions as a scientist having
experience with the equipment and the
reagents that are being presented and do
not start not considered an official
endorsement by varying your angle on any
of these products or services describe
and with that
let me get started I'm really excited to
be here today to talk to you about one
of my favorite topics which is multiplex
fluorescents mediumistic chemistry and
also to relate to you our recent
experience using this new LGU Institute
flex multiplex fluorescent amuse to
chemistry flat platform on our Lego Bond
RX Auto standards
so multiplex community chemistry is a
very powerful tool
it allows us to visualize the context of
target protein expression within human
disease tissues and this context is
provided at multiple levels from a
histopathological context and being able
to understand the and visualize the
expression of an individual target and
play a single Plex ICSA with respect to
features of pootie's as well as to add
additional layers of context on top of
that by adding additional target stains
and so I'll just point your attention
here this is a piece of Crohn's disease
tissue and the histopathological feature
that we're looking at is an abscess
encrypt so these epithelial cells in the
center of the image are starting to lose
their integrity and their arm you cells
starting to invade into the lumen of the
crypt unlike the other epithelial cells
that you see in other parts of the image
and so when we layer on top of this our
biomarker expression
you can see in red that our biomarker of
interest is highly expressed in those
epithelial cells just the ones
associated with that regional crypt
they're also associated with the lamina
propria cells underneath that crypt and
so now with multiplexing we can start to
understand a little bit more about the
context of this expression for instance
we can look at what type of cells are
expressing our target of interest and so
if we look here with CD 68 and 163 in
the same channel here look shown in
green we can see that the majority of
these target expressing cells are
phagocytes they express these markers
and we can see that this highly is a
high degree of CO expression beneath
this lesion old piece of tissue and if
you look over to the left or to the
right of the image and you look at the
phagocytes there they don't call Express
this marker of interest so it's very
specific to this feature of disease now
if you want to delve even further into
this you're considered to look at maybe
some of the molecular biology that's
going on in these cells until here we
layer it on top of that phospho stat1
and so now we can start to understand
the state of these cells perhaps they're
responding to a local burst of
interferon gamma and this helps us build
a complete picture of the molecular
biology of our target with respect to
specific features associated with human
disease now
we see with closed eye tama tree the
greater that we can Plex the more
flexibility we have to ask different
biological questions of our tissues it
really is an immense power and this
grows exponentially with every marker
that we have however the devil is really
in the technical details of how we
optimize and develop and run Meade ihd
athletes to realize a dream of a robust
and reproducible accurate multiplex
fluorescence IESA it does require a lot
of assay optimization this image here
took us three months to develop just as
an example
so I can understand why we need this
optimization and some of the technical
challenges associated with this we
really need to understand a little bit
more about the methods and the reagents
that we use so while there are a number
of different methods and variations that
can be used for multiplex for essence I
see one of the more powerful methods
that's out there and the one that my lab
relies on routinely is an opal style
sequential visualization of termite
doors and so to better understand the
ads the optimization challenging the
limitations we need to understand the
chemistry associated with this method
and so here I've just shown you a
picture you can see epitope one for our
first target antibody an epitope - for
our second and so here say we're trying
to coax look at Co expression of a
biomarker of interest with cd20 as a
marker of b-cells and so we add our
first primary antibody to c20 we had a
secondary reagent conjugated to each RP
to detect that and then we utilize the
term ID chemistry to covalently linked
ear mic floors through an HR p assisted
reaction with tyrosine residues in the
sub site the same subcellular
compartments that our primary antibody
is down this creates a covalent bond
linking the tyrosine residues to the
term light floor and so I've represented
that here with the green circle as our
state media 15 to remind converting to
this triangle and move this covalent Lea
binds to the tear my dress using that
subcellular compartment
so now using an opal style method we'll
use heat induced epitope retrieval to
strip away the first set of antibodies
leaving behind only two covalently bound
termite floors and then we can start our
second or look for Co expression of our
target of interest so here we apply the
primary antibody our second secondary
reagent and our second tier my floor and
now once that's covalently bound we can
understand and visualize Co expression
in the same sub cellular compartments
argot in our green card
and so my lab primarily uses this on
using a homebrew developed method very
similar to the Opel multiplex IHC
workflow using our like a bond rx Auto
Center so it starts out very much like a
standard immunohistochemistry assay we
run through de paraffin ization antigen
retrieval and then we start with the
first primary antibody or for secondary
antibody our first termite floor and
then we use heat induced epitope
retrieval for approximately 10 minutes
to remove that first set of antibodies
leaving behind only that termite floor
and then we repeat this cycle one or two
more times depending on the level of
multiplexing that we're looking for we
counterstain with carts and remelt /
fluorescent microscopy
now this is a really powerful system we
use it routinely it does have some
limitations
now we don't normally run into many of
these limitations as say sequential heat
retrieval effects on tissue and epitopes
as you heat retrieve a tissue you can
start to destroy the histology or that
the morphology of the tissue and you may
be impacting these epitopes negatively
but with a two or three target
co-expression assay we're really not
going above 40 or 50 minutes of heat
induced epitope retrieval so it's not
really a big problem
there's also a limit to the number of
floors that can be resolved you know
once these piece termite floors are
covalently bound to the tissue I'm not
sure that it's possible to easily get
them on so your once you put your 50
down it's picking up that that that
spectral area and you're going to have
to be able to resolve this against the
other fluids that you're adding and
certainly you can do this with things
like multispectral imaging but if you're
like me and you have a standard
fluorescence microscopy whole slide
imaging setup you're really limited to
say your your Dappy your fitzy your
Cyprien sci-fi channels this is not
really a big issue
what does impact everybody and then what
I'm going to focus on is at the
optimization and this comes down to that
chemistry that I talked to you about
really when you're doing multiplexing
you're layering one tier minus a on top
of another and because the tier mine
floors covalently modify the tissue you
can have some adverse interactions so in
the next few slides I'll walk you
through some of these challenges
this has to do a lot with with the type
of work that we do in the lab where
we're really looking at understanding
the expression the cell type-specific
expression of our targets of interest so
we use cell type specific protein
biomarkers for anyone familiar with
doing IHC on these such as cd34 t-cells
see the 24v cells or pen side of caring
for epithelial cells you know that they
have a really robust immune reactivity
because they are a biomarker of that
cell type they're highly expressed on
that cell type and also because they're
so well studied there's been an
evolution of reagents and we now have
very high affinity antibody reagents
available to us so we get these
beautifully robust community chemistry
assays now this can provide some
challenges when you're building a
multiplex asset and I'll just describe
that here so imagine we're looking again
at cd20 we put our primary antibody down
we put our secondary reagent and now we
add our cure my floor and so this
termite floor is now going to convey
latley binds to tyrosine residues in its
local sub cellular compartment and
because we have such robust Demeter
reactivity we've now taken up the
majority of these free tyrosine residues
and so after we strip away with heat our
prime first set of antibodies would come
in with our second set our target of
interest here in red and our second
secondary and term ID because we have
OOP
worry about that just
back to where we were because we have a
limited number of tyrosine residues
available we may get this false
impression that we have a very low
immune reactivity or low expression of
our target of interest within this cd20
positive subset of cells
in addition there's another way in which
termite chemistry can interfere with
subsequent steps and this has to do with
the modification of epitope so even if
we have a really nicely balanced cd20
outside here which is not taking up all
of the free tyrosine residues if our
second or third
epitope contains a tyrosine residue
within that epitope it can now become
covalently modified and so after heat
stripping away our first reagent our
first antibody set and we add our second
antibody now it may not be able to
recognize this pyramide modified epitope
or it may recognize it with a lower
affinity and again this may give us a
false impression that we have weak
expression or no expression of our
target of interest in this de cd20
compartment
now how often do you think you have
Ireson resolution and I see epitope it's
more often than you say so it's a really
nice study by some current and
colleagues a few years back and they
were interested in better understanding
what makes a good IH c epitope and the
nature of IHC epitope and so what they
did is they did epitope mapping study on
the most commonly used antibodies for
breast cancer diagnostics and treatment
including estrogen receptor combs
progesterone receptor clones the vo7 p53
clone and the mid 1 TI 607 call when we
take all of those amino acids from all
of those epitopes and you put them
together and you look at the frequency
of each of those amino acids is really
successful and I see antibodies you see
that's not evenly distributed across all
of the amino acids and there's
particularly an enrichment and so what
you can see is that your tyrosine
residues are in fact the third most
highly enriched or frequent um
constituent of an IH D a good IHC
epitope is actually something that my
lab is currently working on trying to
better understand it and further
optimize this so that we can better
understand how to create epitope
specific or degeneration by you see
antibodies so the bottom line is it
doesn't matter which of those challenges
you're facing you end up with a similar
outcome and you can see that outcome in
this example now just quickly preface
this for the rest of the images in the
presentation you'll see that I've
changed all of the black pixels in the
background and inverted them to white
and I find this a lot easier to see low
level immune reactivity and also to
better be able to see more sensitively
Co expression so here when we look at
red and green Co expression instead of
looking for a shade of yellow it comes
out as black and so it's very easy to
see now being said so what we're looking
at in the left panel is an assay and
we're just looking at our target of
interest here but we started out with an
anti cd20 antibody we did the heat
stripping and now we're looking at the
anti target one and we're just
visualizing target one in red and in
this piece of ulcerative colitis tissue
if you had looked at the control
as you think that our target of interest
was most highly expressed in the area of
mucosal damage and perhaps in some of
the vessel structures deeper within the
tissue whereas in fact when we run our
control and here this was running an ISO
type control instead of an TCP 20
followed by our target one you can see
that the highest degree of mean you're
active ''tis in fact in the germinal
Center B cells in this gut associated
lymphoid tissue and it's really striking
the difference between these two images
now certainly there are a number of
different ways that we could have
troubleshooted this our trouble shot
this sorry what we ended up doing and
what worked really well was simply
diluting out our anti cd20 antibody
which was added first because we went
from using a 1 to 1 concentration and it
were ready to use empty body followed by
target 1 on the left to diluting it down
to a 1 to 15 dilation of the MCCD 20 on
the right and you can see the big impact
that this has had on our visualization
of our target of interest in red and
this did not have an impact on our CD 20
sorry about that this did not have an
impact on our CD 20 as you can see in
green the CD 20-meter activity still
looks really nice even as it's diluted
and we can see that nice black co
expression that i was talking to you
about on the right panel showing that
our target is highly present in TD 20
positive cells
so while this is some termite based
sequential visualization is a really
powerful a safe system it does have some
drawbacks certainly using these termite
floors to develop co-expression acids
particularly when you're looking at
co-expression in the same subcellular
compartment
requires a substantial investment of
time in assay optimization and
troubleshooting for any given
combination of antibodies and so you're
optimizing things like the primary
antibody the order of the primary
antibody application which floor am i
using for which target the concentration
of your primary antibody or termite
floor and I think most unfortunately
it's sometimes you have to reoptimize
one of your really well developed three
target assays when you want to replace
one of those targets within your target
and you realize that putting that that
new antibody into me in that position
just doesn't work with the rest of your
ass and you're getting some of this
interference and so you have to redesign
reoptimize the whole thing there also
certainly some limitations as to how
many targets can be visualized
particularly but you're not particularly
susceptible to these if you're using
again as I mentioned the standard
fluorescence immunised chemistry whole
slide imaging setup as we do where we're
really limited to you know adapter
channel a 50 saturates at five
that being said there are some ways of
getting around you know the limitations
around targets number of targets these
two require more time and specialized
equipment such as multispectral imaging
microscopy or something like x I'm doing
imaging not something that we were to be
using in my lab right now so what can we
do to streamline this process what can
we do to increase our ability to do
multiplexing using standard equipment
this is where the LT View Institute flex
assay comes in so this this adds a
system which has been optimized for use
on that on the bond our data centers is
an alternative fluorescence multiplexing
platform and and the big difference here
is that this system replaces the use of
a secondary antibody reagent as well as
the tear light floors and it replaces us
by bar coding the individual antibodies
so here on the left you can see the
different colored antibodies
representing antibodies that are
specific for individual targets and each
of those target specific antibodies has
a unique DNA barcode and this barcode is
what we're going to use to visualize
eventually our signal as the antibodies
found upon the tissue and so you put
this on the bond it uses a very normal D
wax and retrieval system then you can
add all of your antibodies all at once
because they are unique in that they
have these distinct barcodes on each of
them so a single staining step which
simplifies you know putting your reagent
wand together next we have amplification
so here it's an enzymatic amplification
of a DNA barcode and again this is a
single step that we're doing as opposed
to sequential rounds of stripping away
your primaries and secondaries and then
finally the detection step is also a
single step now you're looking at a
mixture of barcode specific probes that
are each labeled with the unique floor
and in this case we're looking at four
floors that can detect our four targets
of interest all in one step and
coverslip and we can image this in a
fluorescence microscope
so as it stands this is a really nice
ass a system it's a powerful system that
allows us to look at four targets
simultaneously using fairly standard
microscopy setup and on an auto stander
like the bond rx
additional power in this assay and this
is comes as the company is developing
more barcodes so you can imagine you
have more barcodes available now you're
able to put on eight unique data bodies
all at the same time in the first step
you're able to amplify all eight at the
same time and then when it gets to
detection with the pros you're adding
four at a time because that's the limit
of what you can distinguish with your
your your fluorescence microscopy setup
do you image the first four you remove
the coverslip
you remove the original probes you add a
second set of probes to the second set
of antibodies that are already in place
and already amplified and now you can
visualize those next four targets using
this set of probes on your standard
fluorescence microscopy setup take those
images merge them based on the common
nuclear counter stain and now you have a
target nine color or nine nine channel
animals chemistry so there's a lot of
potential with this asset that I'm
really excited about
and and I think one of the other things
that this technology does by removing
that secondary antibody stem and the
term live step is it a voice the
challenges that we associate with your
might chemistry which enables effective
co-expression of targets within the same
sub cellular compartments so if we're
looking at something in the membrane
compartment
we can now layer on 2 or 3 targets
without having to worry about that
interference that I showed you with our
t20 acid
and so all you need here is no special
equipment you can use your bond rx Auto
spanner you can use your standard slide
parson slide scanners all you need on
the old give you specific reagents so
your bar coded DNA or your certain your
bar coded antibodies and the reagents
associated with the amplification and
detection
to institute flex tips have recently
been released with predefined anybody
combinations they've been validated and
optimized for use on Devon direct Auto
scanners and they are the ultimate form
you oncology PDL want it which looks at
PDL one cd68 cd8 pence I declare the Sox
ten in the same channel so that this
assay is useful both for carcinomas as
well as melanomas there's also the PD
one tip which looks at PD one cd45 ro c
d3 and pancetta keratin Sox 10 so to the
next few slides I'm going to walk you
through our experience of being involved
in the alpha and beta testing of these
two kits as well as the development of
some of the newer kits that helping you
is planning to release
so start out with a summary of our
feelings on how it was to use this this
assay system and it's not all for me
this is also from discussions with Diane
years in my lab who performed all of
this beautiful immunity chemistry using
the Ltd platform and so from her
perspective the Ltd method certainly
streamlined multiplex it--see workflow
on the bond direct so that first assay
that I showed you with the term ID that
was an overnight assay that she would
run she'd come in in the morning and
then she'd manually intervene and do the
final target in the morning and now
we're down to about a five hour assay
that looks at pore targets instead of
three so dramatically reduce the amount
of time involved it also streamlined
that how you build your athlete on the
bond and that it was very simple to add
all of your detection antibodies in one
reagent your amplification and your
visualization so it made setting up the
bond one's a lot easier as well what I
was really excited about was the fact
that the LGU methods allow for the use
of a site a seminar near-infrared
channel which is not typical or easily
detectable using HRP in something like t
reminds i7 I have to say as soon as I
saw ultim you present for the first time
I came right back to the lab and I
thought we can do this and I purchased
some termites i7 and we tested it out in
a standard HR PSA using a pens that I
carry anybody and we couldn't see
anything so something about how ulti
view is developed is the use of that
channel really is allows us to take full
advantage of that near infrared range
the validated LGD advocates were very
easy to use very well optimized and I
say this that you know Diane took a look
at the instructions was able to very
easily go through and the optimization I
think we can speak to you based on the
imaging so we imaged a number of
different tissues including inflammatory
bowel disease tissue inflamed skin
inflamed tonsil these lung tissue as
well as cancer tissue and it didn't
matter which tissue that we were using
or where it source was from we were able
to use the same exposure times and get
very comparable results so in that
respect I think it was very well
optimised we were able to see three
co-expression in the same subcellular
compartment so that brings me to the
next point which is that yes
co-expression of multiple targets in the
same compartment does not appear to
suffer from some of the challenges we've
already seen with with tear my base
multiplexing the caveat here being that
my lab did not develop this assay and so
I don't know what was involved in in the
optimization of the assay at Ulta view
but having spoken to a few people in the
lab adults of you who had also had a lot
of experience with termite chemistry it
was a lot simpler to set up this aspect
but that's certainly a question that you
can bring up with all of you and the
teacher also you're not just getting a
kit the LT view support staff were
responsive and highly skilled in both
the arts of ministry chemistry and old
slide imaging and most importantly the
data that we generated is beautiful and
interesting and so I'll walk you to in
the next set of slides some of the
examples of the results that we were
able to to obtain during alpha and beta
testing
so first off I'm going to start and
really the focus here is going to be on
the co-expression of targets within the
same compartment is again this is one of
the things that we do on a routine basis
basis in the lab and this is something
that we really have challenges with with
and spend a lot of time optimizing with
your life so we're starting out we're
looking in some gut associated lymphoid
tissue here in a Crohn's disease patient
so this is a tertiary lymphoid structure
there's no epithelium in the area so
we're not looking at pens that I tear
them pink but we but you can see right
now with pd-1 immune reactivity in red
that there are some high expressing
cells with with more robust immune or
activity and there are some low express
themselves and sort of a range in
between when we layer on top of that
he's 45 ro you can see this is
co-expressed and the same membrane
compartment in these same cells there's
a high degree of correlation between PD
one expression and cd45 overexpress our
expression in terms of the same cells
but what's most impressive is when we
look at the CD tree so this TD tree
signal is exceptionally robust and yet
despite that we can see that the speedy
45 ROP d1 plus of tv3 positive t-cells
maintain this this dynamic range of
expression we can see very high express
errs and very load suppressors you
haven't bleached out that signal like we
saw with that CD 20 answer that I showed
you earlier
you get this beautiful Co expression in
the same subcellular compartment of
three different markers with varying
degrees of material activity
and so we can see this as a higher
magnification in another piece of
Crohn's disease tissue underneath some
epithelial barrier damage here we can
see again you have some cells that have
really high neter activity for PD one in
red as well as some really low activity
and you can see these beautiful park egg
membrane spots of the s8 when we layer
on top of that PD 45 ro you can see
again this is a high degree of
correlation between a cell expressing PD
1 and C 45 RL suggesting that their
memory cells and again we layer on top
of that the city tree and you can see
that that beautiful co-expression all in
the same compartment within the same
cell type
shifting gears we now move to the PDL
one tip and so now we're looking at some
new coastal tissue from Crohn's disease
and so we have epithelium and you can
see the pen set of keratin nicely
identifies this in pink this is in a
size 7 channel but for those who are
interested and so it really nice and
interactivity really clear signal here
and so what I'm showing you here
outlined in yellow are areas of lots of
epithelial barrier integrity so the
mucosal barrier is breaking down and the
lumen of the gut and the host tissue are
now allowed to interact more directly
and so there's an inflammatory response
associated with this when the TD
epithelial cells have a very
disorganized structure as well on the
right hand side were just a few sections
below where the actual epithelium are
but I have outlined in yellow where
there is lots of epithelial barrier
integrity so now when we layer on top of
this RC v 8 signaling dark blue you can
see these cells come particularly
accumulate around the areas of barrier
injury and this is contrasted by the
cd68 lots of phagocytes and here you can
see that they're highly concentrated in
these areas of epithelial barrier gloss
and they're clustered right around the
epithelial cells on the lap and what was
most interesting to me is that when we
look at TBL won immunity reactivity in
green on top of that it's highly
correlated with these cells that are
clustered this is the cd68 lots of
phagocyte that are clustered around the
epithelial barrier injury and as soon as
you start to move away from the barrier
injury the cd68 positive cells are now
PDL one negative what's also really nice
to see is that you have some really
weakened your activity to PDL one in the
actual epithelial cells themselves if
you look at the top of that crypt
structure there's a very faint near
activity for PDL one in the epithelial
cells
it needs inflamed and activated
epithelial cells and this is something
that we've seen with other markers that
activated epithelial cells start
adopting some antigen presenting cell
phenotype they start to express a little
bit of T d68 and MHC class 2 and now
we're able to show that they're also
able to express very sensitively some
degree of PDL one
because this is just another example is
that a lower magnification of an
epithelial barrier injury and so you can
see the paint epithelium moving across
the screen and then where I start that
yellow line that's where we've lost the
epithelial barrier almost completely and
if you follow that yellow line that's
the interface between the host tissue
and the lumen of the gut and moving out
into the lumen of the gut are a number
of immune cells trying to create a
barrier and heal this wound
and so now if we look at cd8 positive
cells you can see they're sort of
clustered in and around that area of
injury as compared to how they are
there's at a higher concentration of and
they are in the more regular lamina
propria at the bottom-left of the screen
but that's nothing compared to what you
see with the CV 68 positive phagocytes
they're highly concentrated in that
wound bed at that interface between the
host and the lumen of the gut and just
as we saw in the previous image we cells
are all PDL one positive and this is
robust immune or activity for both GV 68
mt d l1 then we're still able to see the
nice black co-expression
there's no interference between those
two channels despite the fact that
they're both exceptionally well bust
here and despite this this robust immune
activity if you really take a look at
the image you can still see those little
blue cd8 positive cells interspersed
quite cleanly in that huge concentration
of cd68 video 1 so really beautiful for
Co expression in the same subcellular
compartments
now that's not to say that all of your
PDL one positive cells inflamed tissue
are cd68 positive if we take a look just
a fraction of a millimeter away from
that that area of tissue injury and we
look at some gut associated lymphoid
tissue so again this is a tertiary
lymphoid structure so we see an
accumulation of cd8 positive cells in
here we also see some cd68 positive
phagocytes and I think really
interestingly you see PDL one immune
reactivity but unlike what we saw at
that area of mucosal barrier damage what
we're seeing here is that while there
are a few cd68 positive PDL one positive
cells where this Co expression the bulk
of the PDL one positive cells are cd68
negative
and so now I just want you to use your
imagination now imagine instead of using
this for target assay we were actually
using weak targets we could better
define what those PDL 1 positive selves
are and so here we're just going to move
down slightly in the tissue I don't
unfortunately add serial sections of
this tissue but if we look at a gut
associated lymphoid tissue just a little
bit down using the new antigen
presenting cell
tip that's being developed by all
commute you can see this beautiful cd20
the meteor activity and miscut
associated lymphoid tissue identifying
details in pink we have
TV 68 and CB 163 now in the same channel
is a pan phagocyte marker and you can
see they're all clustered in this area
as well and now we also have CD 11 see
in dark blue and you can see there's
some beautiful dark purple co-expression
between some of the CD 11 c cells and
the cd68 cells in the gut associated
lymphoid tissue there also some T 11 C
only positive cells in this area and
finally we add on top of that our green
MHC class 2 and while there is some Co
expression between MHC class 2 and the
CD 11 C and CV 61-63 positive phagocytes
by and large the bulk of that MHC class
2 immunity activity is in a CD 68
negative population very similar to what
we saw with the PDL one positive
population then got associated lymphoid
tissue and so if we were running these
assays on top of each e now we would
merge this together and we'd be able to
better understand is this MHC class 2 80
68 negative stell population the same as
our PDL one positive population
and so this is
low magnification view looking at the
tissues that we were using for the alpha
beta testing of these tips so we were
using matched non-lethal and regional
Crohn's disease ilium as well as crohn's
disease colon and at this low
magnification you can really nicely see
the pen side of tearing and we're in
pink and where you see that lots of
times out of ten and you see this green
PDL one and in your activity we can
really see it but in both the Crone's
colon as well as in the cons ileum and
you can also see at this low
magnification PDL one immune activity in
gut associated lymphoid tissue and it's
most prominent when it's quickly gulls
are very close to that epithelial very
injury on the bottom right in the clone
so T's : and it starts to get weaker as
you move further away as you see in the
regional constancy billion and the
non-relational crohn's disease colon so
what we see here is that PDL one is
expressed in T V 68 positive self rods
moles of epithelial barrier disruption
but that PDL one is also expressed in te
68 negative cells within gut associated
lymphoid tissue
just to summarize I think you can tell
I'm very excited about this Institute
flex technology it was a very easy to
use tip to run on the bond rx which
allows us to increase our true put using
automation and increase the
reproducibility of the assays it reduces
the complexity of running multiplex I
achieved a base particularly at our lab
where you know the methods of results it
took it took quite a while and to put
together and it also gives us that
additional target in the near infrared
range which is a really powerful
addition adding that fourth channel the
fourth target really gives you
additional insight into your your tissue
biology I'm also very excited because it
addresses some of the challenges that we
associate with tier microexpression
particularly when you're looking at Co
expression of the same subcellular
comparable and again while we didn't
develop these estrogen so I don't have a
really good hands-on experience showing
that it's streamlining the development
of expression assays in conversations
with all of you that does appear to be
the case and certainly this enables more
flexibility to obtain flow cytometry
like gel expression analysis and tissue
just like you saw with those TV one
positive memory t-cells be able to look
at three targets and that membrane
compartments going to find a unique cell
type and so right now we're working to
develop a custom for flex get both of
you to look at some of our targets of
interest teaching in Cincy flex and
defined workflow ahead of the
development of additional barcodes in
this creative and for target ID that
were very much looking forward to so
with that I just like to acknowledge
Diane years in the lab who did all of
units chemistry that you saw from that
first termite assay all the way through
to this last image and to thank the
people at LG view in particular the
director of business development Louie
levy for building this relationship with
us and allowing it to work with them
around the alpha and beta testing on the
bond rx as well as some of the
scientists we've worked with for most of
you Amanda bars in fits your hotel with
that I think we can open the floor to
questions
except perhaps something about these PDL
one positive T V 68 negative cells which
I'm still not sure what they are
Thank You Tracy and Alex for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we had time
for so let's get started our first
question is why wouldn't you use for
conjugated primary antibodies or for
conjugated secondary antibodies to avoid
some of the challenges associated with
pyramide for multiplexing
I think I can field that question I
think this really comes down to being
able to visualize targets very
sensitively and a lot of the work that
we do using looking at it inflammatory
bowel disease and some of the targets
associated there they're very low weak
expression assays and so if we weren't
able to use the amplification that we
get with pyramind or with the LTV chip
we wouldn't be able to detect the using
a multiplex a-sayin formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue this may be
possible maybe it using a frozen tissue
where you can do confocal microscopy and
maybe sensitively detect by using you
know a higher throughput formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded assay it's just not
feasible
now our next question how do I know if
the oath of you kits will work on my
fluorescence microscopy setup
how I didn't take that one and when you
work with all of you
they actually have a set of guidelines
that they can provide to anyone who
would like to to actually staying with
the Institute Plex and that provides the
filters and all the information needed
to set up a microscope and board actual
reading of the same and they can provide
you with the names of the microscope
vendor so they worked with and as well
as all of this ultra setup
and if I could just add to that Tracy I
think it's also important to understand
whether or not the light source that you
have in the camera that you have are
efficient in that near infrared range to
ensure that you're able to detect in
that size that's i7 signal and just to
add to that as well we've tested this on
a number of different microscopy
platforms in the lab we were using a
lake up Versa instrument and it works
really nicely there we've tested this on
a period and scope FL from Leica
this works really nicely but we're just
not able to use the size 7 channel and
in working with ulti view with the bip
scan slides for us on the site active
scan as well as the Polaris mobile
spectral imaging microscopy setup so
really we've seen that it works really
nicely on a number of different setups
now how much time does it take to
optimize and multiplex a HCFA using the
old Seaview technology
I can feel this one Traci this some well
right now as it stands the commercial
kits are preset and so right now it
takes no time at all you buy the kit you
have this beautifully optimized assay
and as I mentioned we found in our hands
looking at a number of different tissues
that it was really well optimized assay
and that we had similar and
interactivity on many different tissue
types from different sources so at this
point I think that's what you're limited
with if you want to start optimizing or
building assays that are using your own
targets of interest that's something
that I think you can do right now
working in a partnership with all of you
and their services lab but but as it
stands them yeah the assays are out of
the box
we are getting so many good questions
and today it looks like we have time for
a couple more let's move on to our next
one are the commercially available kits
only for use in human tissue and if yes
are there plans to develop kits for
mouse tissue analysis
I'll go ahead and take the fun out so
the commercial kits today
are only available for use on human
tissue but in talking with the
development team from all of you there
are plans to work on kits for mouth
tissues but one of the things to keep in
mind is if you talk to the development
team at Ulta view they do provide
services where they will develop custom
antibodies and custom kits for anyone
who is interested so if you have a
special need one of the things that you
can do is reach out to also view
directly and they'll work with you to
develop the kisses suits your particular
needs
technology allow us to identify dim
verse bright expression of t-cell
activation
that's a great question and I think you
can if you look back into one of the
previous slides looking at those those
cd3 positive P V one positive cd45 are
all positive cells I really tried to
emphasize that you can see some stronger
expressing cells and weaker express
themselves both for p1 as well as cd45
ro so I think with some image analysis
which we haven't gotten around to doing
yet you should be able to identify
different populations of T cells based
on based on the tip as is very similar
to what you can do with both cytometry I
think
and it looks like we have time for one
more question how does this fluorescence
multiplex system compared to the Ventana
5 target chroma Jetta cafe that's an
excellent question and one of the things
to keep in mind is that the Ventana 5
Pointz chroma genic si is actually tear
amide based so there actually is a very
big difference between the way that the
city plex and the five pipes
criminogenic work and the 5 paisa
criminogenic originally came out for
their resource platform so it does have
its basis in the to remind source and so
that is the biggest difference between
the two kits and if you think back to
the original size and Alex's
presentation that show the some of the
pluses and minuses of working with the
tera my floors that's where you're going
to find the largest difference in the
two technologies thank you again
Tracy and Alex do you have any final
comments for our audience
thank you so much for attending and
please feel free to keep questions
coming and less elaborate seen
throughout those to us if you have any
additional questions that we didn't have
time to answer today and it was a
pleasure to present for you
like why before we go
go ahead Alex there's a real pleasure to
be been to you and yes I'd be happy to
answer any additional questions
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank laberd's and our
sponsor like a bio system for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
roommate of 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with their colleagues to Madness
today's live event until next time
goodbye